enfin
bonjour à tous je suis c'est quoi le taq
taq aujourd'hui nous allons parler de la
venue de son rôle qu'appelle-t-on armées
françaises l'appellation exacte de
l'armée française les forces armées
françaises elle est constituée de temps
qu'on force quels sont ceux trop fort
les différentes forces de l'armée sont
les suivantes la force terrestre appelé
l'armée de terre la force navale appelé
la marine nationale la force aérienne et
aérospatial appelé l'armée de l'air
combien de militaires contre l'armée
l'armée emploiera en fin 2015 exactement
265 1846 militaire ce nombre est en
constante diminution depuis 2008 alors
que le nombre de théâtres d'opération
n'a jamais été aussi important et la
nature des missions aussi diversifiée à
chaque instant vingt mille soldats sont
engagés dans les opérations extérieures
opex comme au mali tchad irak liban et
plus de dix mille soldats pour les
opérations intérieures au pink notamment
avec le renforcement de vigipirate et
quelles sont ses missions ses missions
sont selon le livre blanc défense et
sécurité nationale de 2013 au nombre de
cinq que nous allons détailler toute
première mission protéger le territoire
national et leurs ressortissants
français et garantir la continuité des
fonctions essentielles de la nation cela
consiste entre autres à protéger le
territoire des attaques terroristes des
cyber attaques de toute agression d'un
autre état et des attaques contre des
ressortissants français à l'étranger
deuxièmement garantir avec nos
partenaires et alliés la sécurité de
l'europe et de l'espace nord atlantique
en effet la sécurité de la france est
étroitement lié
celle de l'ensemble de l'europe la
stabilité dont l'ensemble des pays de
l'union européenne restent aussi une
priorité importante
troisièmement stabilisé avec nos
partenaires et alliés le voisinage de
l'europe il est en effet de l'intérêt de
la france et de l'union européenne
qu'aucune menace n'apparaissent dans le
voisinage immédiat la sécurité des pays
voisins à la france a donc un caractère
prioritaire les régions du sahel en
afrique et de la méditerranée sont
également des zones d'intérêt
prioritaire pour la france
quatrièmement participer à la stabilité
du proche orient et du golfe arabo
persique
cette zone qui connaît de nombreux
conflits est un enjeu majeur pour la
france et l'europe et nos alliés de
l'otan c'est non seulement une grande
réserve énergétique mais également l'une
des principales voies de transit de
l'économie mondiale le détroit d'ormuz
et le passage obligé de plus ou moins 30
% des exportations mondiales de pétrole
cinquièmement contribuer à la paix dans
le monde son positionnement politique
dans le monde les valeurs qu'elle défend
sa présence partout sur le blog grâce
aux autres maires confère à la france
des intérêts sur tous les continents
koffi pour la france et l'europe la
sécurité de l'océan indien voies d'accès
maritimes vers l'asie et de ce point de
vue une priorité absolue en effet
l'océan qui entoure la réunion se situe
au coeur d'enjeux stratégiques mondiaux
c'est pourquoi le port de la pointe des
galets et la troisième plus grande base
navale de france
j'espère que le rôle des forces armées
françaises et maintenant plus clair pour
vous et que vous avez compris son
utilité à bientôt pour un nouvel épisode